HBO's Chernobyl purports to show not
just the causes of the historic nuclear
accident but the bureaucracy that stood
in the way of rescue and recovery in the
aftermath with the real-life history
being shrouded in such secrecy it's a
story that can't help but leave some
questions unanswered a lot of numbers
get thrown around in Chernobyl
when Valeri Lagasse explains the worst
case scenario to the Soviet Central
Committee we get figures of potential
fatalities that are downright
catastrophic when the gossip gives the
numbers needed to contain the disaster
from the cost it demands to the years it
will take and the lives that will be
lost in the process
it sounds like horrific science-fiction
Lucia and the Ukraine impact means
completely uninhabitable for a minimum
of 100 years but one number audiences
don't get is a concrete death toll part
of the problem is the Soviet Union's
lack of records relating to the topic
but another trickier issue is the way
radiation exposure actually causes death
while many people lost their lives in
the disasters immediate aftermath there
were also untold numbers whose deaths
were more indirect caused by radiation
related illnesses that took years to
develop notes at the end of the series
put the death toll between 4,000 and 93
thousand but those numbers are far from
universally accepted the us-based
Union of Concerned Scientists estimates
between 4,000 and 27,000 lives lost
while Greenpeace believes it to be in
the range of 93 thousand to 200,000
Chernobyl showrunner Craig Mazin also
shared estimates he's read that put the
death toll closer to a million the
estimates are so varied that
unfortunately when it comes to the
question of how many people died from
the Chernobyl disaster the only answer
we can all agree on is too many one of
the most heartbreaking chapters in
Chernobyl comes in the 4th episode in
which we follow a trio of Soviet
Liquidators tasked with killing any
animals mostly domesticated pets left
behind in abandoned villages fleeing
civilians were not allowed to bring pets
with them for the fear the pets could
contaminate humans while the episode was
difficult for some viewers to watch
showrunner Craig Mazin has said that his
dramatized story is still a toned-down
version of what actually occurred
radioactive
so they have to go but it's not hard
they're mostly pets they're happy to see
you they run right up to you
bang but did the liquidators really
manage to wipe out all the pets who are
left behind in the evacuations not quite
according to the SPCA international and
the clean futures fund who frequently
visit the Chernobyl exclusion zone to
provide spaying neutering and
vaccination services over 800 dogs and
cats still live in the area subsisting
off of volunteer donations and their own
foraging skills to survive in 2019 SPCA
International announced that for the
first time 15 dogs with radiation levels
low enough to be considered safe were
taken from the exclusion zone and
adopted by homes in the United States
Chernobyl's fourth episode opens with an
elderly woman milking a cow while a
Soviet soldier demands that she evacuate
the scene is inspired by true stories of
people who return to their homes in the
exclusion zone in the years following
the meltdown
despite being legally barred from doing
so amazingly many of those people are
still there call them courageous or just
plain reckless Oh God and a routine code
live here on a permanent basis in 2017
the Irish Times visited the so called
some mostly for self settlers those who
illegally returned to Chernobyl to live
there after the disaster despite
warnings from scientists The Times said
around 200 people still made their homes
there some of whom were living well into
their 80s but don't take their presents
as evidence that the exclusion zone is
safe while residents may not be dropping
dead in the grisly manners of
Chernobyl's first responders cancer
diagnosis particularly thyroid cancer
and leukemia have spiked since the
accident despite these real dangers the
lives of the self settlers aren't nearly
as post-apocalyptic as you might think
and according to some who shared their
stories with the media things where they
live are just fine though the residents
aren't officially sanctioned by the
government their presence is tolerated
and they're given limited support
luchenko have been married 53 years they
say they don't need anything from anyone
the true noble series opens two years
after the disaster with Valeri Lagasse
recording his recollections on audio
tapes before hanging himself the gossip
makes like he's taking out the trash to
fool his KGB watchman and uses the
opportunity to drop the tapes
a nearby building a note at the end of
the series finale tells us that
Lagasse's records were circulated among
the soviet scientific community which
seems to confirm that this part of the
story is accurate however we never learn
hula gossip expects to retrieve the
tapes we don't know if he's been in
contact with a journalist or perhaps
with another scientist it's not clear
how his influential records actually get
out into the world speaking to the
cheatsheet about how he prepared for the
role of ligase Jared Harris said one of
his biggest challenges was that there
was little historical record left on the
gossip to study just like it's
threatened in the show the Soviet Union
did indeed do a good deal to erase him
from history Harris also said he never
listened to the gossips audio tapes and
he has good reason they don't exist
he explained there were no audio tapes
he left behind journals but that's not
as cinematic as audio tapes Chernobyl's
conclusion includes a 2006 quote from
Mikhail Gorbachev the Soviet Union's
final leader it reads the nuclear
meltdown at Chernobyl was perhaps the
true cause of the collapse of the Soviet
Union but the series doesn't explore
what exactly that statement means in
2013 mark Joseph Stern wrote an article
for Slate explaining what he called the
nuclear theory of the USSR's collapse
he explained that shortly before the
explosion at Chernobyl Gorbachev had
already introduced the policy of
glasnost or openness of ideas expression
in institutional transparency Stern
wrote that it was Gorbachev's way of
combating the widespread practice of
censoring information and keeping
secrets that the Chernobyl series does
such a good job of conveying the policy
of glasnost is widely credited with
fueling the USSR's eventual disillusion
in 1991 the aftermath of the Chernobyl
accident Stern argues is what wound up
fueling Blaz knows the most Stern wrote
that before Chernobyl most Soviet
citizens quote believed in the Soviet
system forgave its flaws and hoped for a
better future but the reactor explosion
and everything that came to light
afterwards put questions in the minds of
citizens crucial questions about what
was in their food and water whether they
should believe what the government was
telling them that new distrust for the
Soviet state according to the theory
made the USSR's demise inevitable the
horrible aftermath of Chernobyl as
depicted in HBO's miniseries
probably has plenty of viewers wondering
if what happened in 1986 Ukraine could
happen again in the United States or
elsewhere in 2016 Business Insider
talked to Chernobyl expert and author
Andrew leather Barrow the writer and
photographer took the opportunity to
explain why what happened at Chernobyl
simply couldn't happen in the US the key
he says is graphite as the series makes
clear in its final episode the power
plants graphite tipped control rods are
what caused the reactor explosion
accelerating the nuclear reaction
instead of helping to shut it down
according to leather Barrow using those
rods in the real-life reactor was quote
an incredibly foolish decision
thankfully American reactors use water
instead of graphite to serve that
function as leather Baro explained to
Business Insider there's absolutely no
way the accident at Chernobyl could have
happened at any American commercial
power reactor but before you breathe
easier this doesn't mean a meltdown
can't happen at a nuclear power plant in
the u.s. Americans learn to meltdown at
one of their plants was possible in 1979
s Three Mile Island incident just as the
Japanese learned in 2011 with the
Fukushima meltdown but the specific
event that triggered the Chernobyl
accident couldn't happen in the u.s.
meaning the chance of any Americans
having to stumble around shovel and
graphite off of rooftops in the years to
come is pretty much close to zero check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]